Donald Trump has gone from media
sideshow to the main event he came out
strong in the Republican primaries on
Super Tuesday winning seven states major
states it's Georgia Alabama
Massachusetts Tennessee Virginia
Arkansas Vermont we get it how could a
bigoted businessman get so popular
well many Americans are frustrated by
the inability to find work and feel
disenfranchised by the current system
and their frustration is not unfounded
only 40% of Americans have an
associate's degree or above the 2008
recession may be over by definition but
in the most economically distressed ZIP
codes in America half of adults don't
even have a job while the rich have
bounced back and are doing better than
ever by 2012 we were as unequal as we
were in 1929 enter Trump he says he's
rich enough to not be in anybody's
pocket when all the establishment
candidates are getting donations from
the same corporations and billionaire
donors
well that resonates with people he says
that he's against free trade agreements
supported by both Republicans and
Democrats that have taken a heavy toll
on the middle and working classes it's
no wonder that Trump is outperforming
his rivals especially in poor states and
counties the other candidates just
aren't appealing to most Americans
economic concerns in fact these concerns
are legitimate and Trump's progressive
counterpart Bernie Sanders has made them
the cornerstone of his campaign
another reason Trump has been successful
white America which is getting smaller
by 2060 five whites will be less than
half of the American population it's a
demographic reality ripe for Trump's
anti-immigrant rhetoric will build the
hole of how I will build the wall in
Mexico is going to pay for it Trump
validates that dangerous blame game he
may be all talk and little subs
but maybe that's the point at a time
when the world feels complicated Trump
is simple and he's filling a void in
conservative politics that the other
Republican candidates haven't been able
to one that might just win him the
nomination